can you guys talk about what you see the
most opportunity and like what's the
coolest part about crypto and then
what's the dumbest thing to you about
crypto
um i can start i mean i think i'll start
with the dumbest i think it's not
necessarily about crypto but i think the
dumbest thing about it right now is sort
of the fake
the fake embracing of it you see a lot
of people doing like you said before a
couple years ago people weren't paying
attention
and like just the twitter
behavior around it like all of these
people sort of
making their twitter avatars board apes
and all of these things it's like i
don't know i feel like we're going to
look back and it will be sort of this
strange moment where everybody felt that
they had to kind of pretend like they
were crypto people
kind of even before they really
understand the technology
um so a little bit i guess of just like
the parading around on social media
around crypto is the thing that i find
to be sort of the dumbest um i'm really
excited to to personally learn more
about defy and to go into next year and
to try to better cover that industry
because i think that
there's a lot of coverage around nfts
and there's a lot of coverage around
kind of just web 3
broadly um
and even around dows there's coverage
and a lot of conversation but i think
that because d5 is sort of inherently
less sexy in that it's more
infrastructure and behind the scenes
there's been a lot less conversation
around it so i think that's probably the
sector that i'm most interested in and
covering and excited about awesome yeah
there's so much to be excited about uh
in crypto and
yeah i mean definitely
uh i'm excited with nfps as i said
gaming um d5 i'm sort of interested in
seeing how
that
evolves it's a not i think not an easy
area for people to get into so i'm sort
of looking at how you know d5 protocols
are tackling that problem
um and yeah obviously there's the
specter of regulation you know what are
we going to see here
i think it's going to be a big year for
compliance startups
that can help you know different
companies enter crypto and already have
things like kyc and aml uh you know it's
things that they don't have to worry
about um and
yeah i think also
kate kind of touched on this but yeah
some of the silliest things about crypto
it's it's a little cringe-worthy at
times just seeing on twitter like how
people try to tweet and change the
language and their profiles you know to
make it seem like they're cool and with
it when they're really just
hopping on board um so that can be a
little silly sometimes to look at and
also there's just some silly stuff with
nfps of course you know like uh i think
i saw today that the first ever like
text message sent on about a phone is
like going up for auction as an nft so
but it's also fun to see those things
too nice i am uh uh convinced and i
don't remember hannah kate which one of
you said it but uh this whole idea of
like changing the profile picture to not
your face
uh doesn't make sense unless you're
completely suit anonymous so there's you
know i think it's like punk six five two
nine right where uh that is the entire
point of the identity is that it is a
pseudo-anonymous person it's known by
that identity uh and it's talking about
that etc that makes a ton of sense then
but i think that there's something
around like
social media is a brand and so like
people recognize your profile picture as
much as they recognize your name and
like that when they're seeing you
especially as you build a bigger
audience and so
the ability to tell the difference
between the apes or the punks or
whatever is actually like much harder
than i think people realize and so if
you use your real name but you use like
basically a pseudo-anonymous photo uh i
think that people don't understand like
the long-term implications of that like
that actually may be detrimental to the
um kind of use of social media except
for to the um maybe like a brand
building or like community building
within that community so if you have a
obviously an ape like you basically
build you know kind of um
uh positively with other people in that
community but outside everyone's like
hey man like who are you uh yeah
if you want to build a long-term brand
with your nfc if it's an ape or a crypto
punk or whatever it is it's a long term
commitment and so
sure if you keep it for years you can
develop a brand and i know a lot of
people are really excited about the
ability to kind of create a brand out of
their
metaverse avatar but most these people
probably will be changing their pictures
back to
their normal photos or other nfts and
things like that in which case you know
i think it's more of just an experiment
which is completely fine and great and i
think it's really fascinating to see i
just think at times it's also like
a really silly way of trying to show
that you're
hip
with the new internet trends or hip with
the crypto jargon that is probably not
as effective as
those people think when it comes to
actually impressing those people who are
more crypto native i'm guessing they
probably can identify the people who
are just kind of like hannah said
hopping up onto the bandwagon in 2021
i don't know which one of you guys want
to answer this but is it fair to say
that uh the startup community looks at
uh the moves by like a facebook becoming
meta and doing all that are they hopping
on the bandwagon as well or is this
something that's much more kind of like
organic to a big company like that like
what do you hear from founders and some
of these startups yeah well the founder
of the sandbox the other day really came
down on on meta um and said that his
main mission right now is to defend
against these big you know big tech
giants coming into the metaverse and he
just doesn't think that it's possible
for them to really make a difference in
this space uh that will benefit users uh
that they're too beholden to their
shareholders so you know i think it'll
be really interesting to see uh sort of
that clash down the line um so yeah i
would say there there are rumblings
among founders you know there is
sort of this
you know
sort of i guess shaking their heads uh
about this um and it's interesting also
to see too like you know um solana labs
like there
they told me a few weeks ago that
they're they've talked to literally
every social media platform you know
that
big tech giants are interested in this
space and they're coming in